let me ask
the question that you've answered in
many ways already but
let's explicitly look at what is money
well as you know that's my favorite
question yes
that uh is the name of the show i just
launched
the what is money show um
[Music]
clearly the we could say that the
bitcoin rabbit hole is what's led me to
explore a lot of these ideas
in depth and i think as we've
demonstrated today
it goes well beyond just the economic
sphere when you start to think about
things like
exchange and morality and time
preference
and civilization so
i love the question what is money i
think it is the key to incepting
a deeper understanding of the world into
people that if you actually just start
to ask
the seemingly simple question it un
services more and more layers of truth
and
i i recently i just wrote a piece i
think i have
30 something answers to this question so
there's so sometimes it's actually
a more systematic way of asking the
question of what is the meaning of life
you know
there are some questions that are almost
unanswerable
but in their asking allow you to
deeply unders get closer to truth deeply
understand
the nature of our human existence and
the meaning of life is almost like this
uh
initial philosopher's uh striving
towards that
if if money is indeed as as fundamental
as
as as you have described especially in
the context of value being fundamental
then that is a really that's a more
let's take a 21st century way of asking
the same question about what is the
meaning of life
you mentioned that it's a meta property
out of the list of many ways to answer
that question
how would you help people to think about
that yeah the
first
most serious answer comes from the
school of austrian economics
and it defines money as a universal
medium
of exchange so
this would be any good that is used
held and used purely for purposes of
facilitating exchange
so in the configuration of demand
for any particular asset it's bifurcated
between its utility which is something a
service that it can render to you
in real time whether it's you know
if it's water you're thirsty that's the
utility of water is that it can quench
your thirst
whereas the marketability would be the
expectation of future exchange
that other people would want this asset
in the future to trade it for
whatever they may have money
is just going to be the good in any
trading economy that has the highest
proportion of marketability relative to
utility
so today that would be gold gold has
utility it's used in electronics it's
used in dental dentistry and whatnot
but it's largely used as a store value
across time
and that's what it's been used for for 5
000 years so
if we say gold has a 10 trillion dollar
market cap
maybe 2 trillion of that is its utility
value or it's actually
demand for use in computers and
dentistry and an 8 trillion of that is
demand for its use as a store value
money the marketability aspects of money
boils down to five services that money
can render
money needs to be divisible it needs to
be durable
it needs to be recognizable needs to be
portable and it needs to be scarce
so i'll gloss over a lot of history with
this and just say that
historically money's always been a
technology still is a technology or a
tool
i use these terms interchangeably and
you think of a technology as just a more
sophisticated tool effectively
of for to best satisfy those properties
monetary metals
were determined to be the most
satisfactory tool
the most divisible most durable most
recognizable most portable tool
in the marketplace of the monetary
metals gold was the most scarce
as quantified by either its stock to
flow ratio
or its inflation resistance so simple
way to say this is that
people always prefer the money most
resistant to inflation
that's a nice definition of scarcity in
the context the money
is uh if you were to measure it the
resistance to inflation
also how hard is it to artificially
increase the supply that's applied
that is the hardness of money and that's
why gold is hard money because alchemy
is hard
that's right because no one cracked
alchemy so gold became money
so that's such a nice
clean explanation of what is money with
the five elements
and gold ultimately won out because of
the last piece of scarcity
that's right and to get to maybe dig a
little deeper there so scarcity
we commonly think of scarcity as
strictly a supply
uh property where if there's not much of
something then it's scarce
but it's not actually true scarcity
occurs when demand
exceeds supply so when there's more
demand
than the supply can justify the thing
becomes an economic good
and it establishes itself a market price
so there's more demand for the thing
than the supply can satisfy
the unique thing about money as a
concept at least
is that demand always exceeds supply
there's never enough money to satisfy
everyone right because
another definition for money it's the
most
marketable good so it can be trade it
can be traded for any other good
service piece of knowledge in the
marketplace so
be humans being what we are we're never
satisfied right we always want more of
something whatever it may be
so money as the ultimate token of
obtaining that something
is always scarce as a concept
but the problem with the money is that
if you can
as you alluded to easily increase its
supply then all of a sudden you can
compromise the scarcity of it over time
uh and you can rob people through
inflation
so that's why the market settled on gold
as money
and robbing is reallocating the value
that i so essentially
the one property like why scarcity
is important is uh it adds a lot more
friction to the
reallocation uh
like through essentially violence or
implied violence
well it prevents it through cost of
extraction too so if you want to go out
and dilute gold holders today
you have to go out into the world and
mine gold it's a very expensive process
that process tends to find equilibrium
where production cost equals a market
value of gold so if market value is 2
000
an ounce today of gold its production
cost is going to be around there
that's the natural market equilibrium so
that way gold miners cannot just dilute
people over time whereas you look at
something like fiat currency
which might we're jumping ahead a little
bit but its production cost is zero
so there's a reason the market value of
fiat currency historically has always
converged to zero
because its production cost is near zero
so the net the extension to that
question might be how did we get
from gold to paper currency and again
this is rooted in the properties of
money
as good as monetary metals were and as
good as gold is as money
at holding value across time it's rather
limited
in terms of portability it is not as
useful for moving value across space
this is another definition of money by
the way a social device for moving value
across space and time so
to rectify this technological
shortcoming of gold
we introduced first of all
the custody of gold was gradually
centralized in
to more into fewer and fewer warehousing
operations
this is because there are economies of
scale associated with using
um gold as money and that if you
centralize the custody
the warehouse owner can then issue a
paper receipt
called the warehouse receipt for that
gold and then market participants can
trade that paper
as if it's good as gold and everyone has
an option at any time to go and redeem
real gold
from the warehouse so that system works
until the problem with it is that it
introduces the need to trust the
custodian so it's introducing
counterparty risk in the form of the
custodian and now
should that warehouse choose to increase
the supply
of paper notes to gold beyond its supply
so if it's got
a three tons of gold then it issues six
tons worth of
paper receipts all of a sudden it's
participating in a fraud
it's basically lying it's representing
that it has more gold than it actually
does
and this is that is the pathway that we
got into banking and central banking
is we needed a convenience mechanism to
rectify the portability shortcomings of
gold
we needed to be able to move value
across space right gold was doing a
great job at moving value over time but
not space
paper currency gave us the ability to
move value across space
but it introduced this attack vector for
warehouse operators which became banks
which became central banks to modify the
supply
to suit their own political agendas
added the snooze button
allows you to do just do a little fraud
get something for nothing
something just a little bit at first
yeah just just
just this one morning just a little bit
i mean i don't know if you can speak to
um
the birth of uh fiat currency is there
some interesting
um characteristics to that
those early steps that created it like
could it
have been averted or was this the
natural
progression of um of governments
you know what's funny is that central
banking
was initially designed to be the
custodian of gold
right so they were going to custody the
gold
issue paper on top of it
and they would maintain you could trust
the public stamp effectively you could
trust that the central bank had as much
gold on reserve as they said they had
and they were supposed to be the
trustworthy institution so we pl we went
from placing our trust
in a free market game theoretic process
or trust in gold
and we began trusting this institution
instead
this that institution would not have
arisen
if the portability of gold was really
high
if we could have somehow sent gold
across a telecommunications channel
there would have been no need for a
central bank everyone could have custody
their gold
in any any information bearing medium
frankly and they could beam it around
the world
at any time so this whole institution
itself
is rooted in a technological shortcoming
of gold so i think it's
another way to think about that is maybe
had there been
all the gold in the world today fills
two olympic sized swimming pools
all the gold mined throughout all of
human history so there's not a lot
right what if there had been just like
way more there's just been i don't know
20 000 olympic swimming pools worth
portability wouldn't have been as much
of an issue right we could have
and this is to say assuming gold was
still the most scarce medal in all these
things
um portability would have been less of
an issue we would have need
we would have had less dependence or
need for a central bank
so i think it's it's kind of
idiosyncratic and that we just
happened to end up here on this planet
with a certain amount of gold it best
satisfy the properties of money
and a certain amount of humans
geographically dispersed
such that portability had certain
properties that you want to achieve
for humans in the geographical space to
be able to be a
um exchange value became more of an
issue as we globalized
right as it became more of a global
society we needed
money that could move across space
really fast right so we could trade in
international
capital markets so that
drove the central bank to become the
dominant institution of the world
and if you follow the flows of gold
throughout history
you know i've been watching this uh
documentary on world war one in world
war
ii on netflix i think it's called world
war ii in color
oh yeah that's really good it's so good
when i say gold has been the governor of
governments or gold is geopolitical
money like it is the base layer
operating system
has been the baseline operating system
for analog society so it's always been
about who controls the gold
is who makes the rules and that's in
that
context is why bitcoin is so interesting
because it is the disrupter to
this base level operating system that's
functioned for all of
human history
you